and this last thing you're gonna learn
how to find the lateral area surface
area and volume of a cylinder and the
first thing we want to talk about are
the formulas and what's interesting if
you're familiar with prisms you can
think of a cylinder kind of like a
circular prism in a sense because you've
got a these two parallel and congruent
bases which in this case their circles
separated by the height so what you can
do is you could take the perimeter of
the base okay the perimeter of this
circle and multiply it by the height and
the perimeter of a circle is just the
circumference that's 2 PI R times the
height so instead of memorizing this
formula you can memorize the formula for
a prism and then just go ahead and
substitute in the circle for the
perimeter of the circumference for
surface area are taking the lateral area
which is the area of the sides but then
you're adding on the area of the base
times 2 since we have a top and a bottom
so surface area is like the total area
but of course when you find the area of
a circle that's PI R squared and we have
two of those so 2 PI R squared and the
lateral area we already talked about
that that's 2 pi RH so a lot of times
students like to memorize this formula
but I kind of like to use the general
formula so there's little bit less for
me to memorize and then the last thing
is to find the volume that's the area of
the base but of course we said the base
is a circle so that's PI R squared times
the height so we could think of PI R
squared H for volume let's go ahead and
do this problem for number 1 here we
want to find the lateral area which is
the perimeter of the base 2 pi R that's
the circumference times the height now
keep in mind if I was to cut this and
unroll it you would have like a
rectangle that makes up the sides and
then at the top you have like a circle
and the bottom you'd have a circle but
the lateral area is just the area of
this rectangle this right here
represents this circumference of the
circle which is 2 PI R times the height
ok and that's the area of a rectangle
right so that's where that form that
comes from so we have 2 pi times the
radius which is 4 times the height which
is 7 and that comes out to 56 pi inches
squared so inches squared since its area
it's like you're covering the surface
here with little
by one square inches you know little
squares so for surface area now what
we're going to do is we're going to add
on these two bases in addition to the
lateral area so we've got area of a
circle is PI R squared so that's going
to be pi times 4 squared but then you
have two of them so we have to double
that so that's going to be 16 times 2
which is 32 pi plus the lateral area
which that's the area of the side so
that's going to give us 88 pi inches
squared for the surface area or the
total area last part is finding the
volume that's like if you were going to
fill this up with water like this is a
glass how much [ __ ] would that contain
well we're gonna do the area of the base
which is a circle PI R squared times the
height the radius we said was 4 squared
and the height is 7 so let's see that
it's gonna be 16 times 7 which is a
hundred and 12 PI inches cubed so it's
like you're filling this up with like
little one by one by one ice cubes and
you're that's how many we fill up the
inside of that glass now if you want to
see more about like cones and pyramids
and prisms and all the different shapes
together I put together a comprehensive
video right there where we go through
all the different shapes when we talk
about how the formulas are related and
easy way to memorize them follow me over
that video we'll dive into some more
examples